Matt Damon related to Ben Affleck
actually they did some genealogy thing
and we found out that that we have some
relative from the 1600s who was a who
was a bricklayer who uh is is we have in
common a common ancestor so apparently
we're related that's crazy it's Matt
Damon in Game of Thrones are you in Game
of Thrones I'm into Game of Thrones but
I'm not in Game of Thrones is Matt Damon
moving Niceville Florida I'm not there
are stories that come on the internet
various towns have been told that I'm
moving to about six or seven different
towns small towns in different states
don't know where that comes from I think
it's just wishful thinking they want you
to move to their Town
um is Matt Damon dead I hope not
terrible he's not dead well maybe
culturally speaking
maybe I'm over
he's so dead